das gab es so noch nie es wäre ein
naturspektakel dass die menschheit so
noch nie erlebt hat die rede ist von
einer möglichen explosion also supernova
des riesensterns beteigeuze ein
gigantisches strahlen bomba dem ort
direkt in unserer kosmischen
nachbarschaft wäre die folge
und es wäre nicht folgenlos für die erde
aber wie gefährlich kann uns der stern
tod werden klick zum science fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und activity
glocke nur dann verpassen sie nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen supernovae
konnten wir hier auf der erde schon ein
paar sehen allerdings sind sie meistens
millionen lichtjahre entfernt und nur
ein kleiner punkt der gerade mal mit
leistungsfähigen teleskopen gesehen
werden kann und es gab auch welche in
der nähe unserer erde wie zb essent 1054
nach der wir unser netzwerk mit
zahlreichen richtig coolen wissenschafts
kanälen benannt haben es 1054
explodierte im jahr 1054 und hinterließ
den krebsnebel in sechs 1500 lichtjahren
entfernung
sie war hier von der erde aus gut zu
sehen und es 1006 erhellte sogar die
erde zusätzlich und konnte tagsüber am
himmel gesehen werden sie war 7000
lichtjahre entfernt beteigeuze kennt man
vielleicht aus per anhalter durch die
galaxis da spielen dessen hypothetischen
exoplaneten beteigeuze fünf und sieben
eine nebenrolle
peter gosse ist nur 700 lichtjahre
entfernt und da wird eine supernova eine
ganz andere geschichte eigentlich gehört
mit zu den sechs bis sieben hellsten
stern am nachthimmel es handelt sich um
den schulter stern des orion ein roter
über riese und er macht dieser
bezeichnung wirklich alle ehre denn
dieser stern hat den tausendfachen
durchmesser der sonne ein raumschiff
wäre rund zehn jahre unterwegs um den
stern zu umrunden
doch nicht nur das außerdem hat
beteigeuze auch eine etwa 10.000 mal
größere leuchtkraft als die sonne doch
seit oktober 2009 10 verliert der stern
an helligkeit und das nicht zu knapp so
sehen in forschungsteams derzeit erst an
position 21 sein helligkeitsverlust ist
also enorm
doch es gibt weitere veränderungen des
roten überriesen es auch seine
temperatur hat sich verändert 105
sich kelvin weniger werden derzeit
gemessen als während seines helligkeits
maximums liegt das alles an seinen
variablen licht zyklen man weiß dass
dieser stern regelmäßig seine helligkeit
ändert möglicherweise kann der
derzeitige verlust der helligkeit damit
erklärt werden dass sich das minimum der
beiden licht zyklen er doch
möglicherweise steht beteigeuze auch
kurz vor einer supernova also einer
absolut wahnsinnigen explosion so
beenden rote überriesen ihr
vergleichsweise kurzes sternen leben und
das wird ein absoluter hammer wir können
wirklich außergewöhnliches erwarten denn
es handelt sich um eine riesige
energiemenge die dann freigesetzt wird
innerhalb von wenigen tagen wird die
menge an energie frei wie durch die
sonne in ihrem gesamten leben wo mehrere
millionen jahre hat der über diese jetzt
energie dadurch bezogen das atomkerne
verschmolzen sind doch jetzt könnte
dieser nukleare brennstoff in seinem
fusions ofen aufgebraucht seien die
folge der stern kollabiert und dabei
wird seine gesamte gashülle ins all
katapultiert eine absolute mega super
nova das alles ist ein riesiges inferno
in dessen zentrum sich dann letztendlich
ein neutronenstern oder aber sogar ein
schwarzes loch bildet und das alles wird
sogar noch jahrtausende später folgen
haben
die gassen der explosionswolke werden
selbst dann noch mehrere millionen grad
heiß sein
eigentlich unvorstellbar der über riese
würde bei einer supernova sogar tagsüber
von uns am himmel zu sehen sein
und nachts heller strahlen als der
vollmond dabei sind supernova in der
milchstraße gar nicht so selten sterne
and nähe etwa dreimal in dem zeitraum
eines jahre 100 historische
überlieferungen legen nahe dass solche
supernovae nie in einer so kurzen
distanz zur erde stattgefunden haben
eben die nächste supernova aller zeiten
allerdings besteht keine gefahr denn
astronomie teams gehen davon aus dass
eine künftige explosion für das leben
auf der erde ungefährlich ist ein
massensterben auf der erde würde wohl
durch eine supernova ausgelöst werden
die etwa 50 lichtjahre von uns entfernt
ist doch ganz spurlos würde der stern
tod von beteigeuze dann wohl doch nicht
an uns vorbeigehen dann eine menge gamma
und röntgenstrahlung würde freigesetzt
werden die dann auch die erde erreicht
durch eine chemische kettenreaktion in
der hand
wäre könnte die ozonschicht gestört
werden da diese uns aber vor zu viel uv
licht der sonne bewahrt würden wir uns
dann schneller als sonst einen
sonnenbrand einhandeln zudem es ja auch
noch gar nicht abschließend geklärt dass
tatsächlich eine supernova kurz bevor
steht auch wenn klar ist dass der über
riese sich in seinen letzten zügen
befindet doch diese können gleich morgen
stattfinden oder aber auch erst in 1000
jahren dazu der astrophysiker hans
thomas janka vom max-planck-institut in
garching im spiegel unseren theorien
zufolge müssten der supernova explosion
eigentlich heftige energie aus welche
vorausgehen die seine helligkeit sogar
steigern würden möglicherweise hat der
über riese auch nur eine große
staubwolke ausgestoßen die in dunkler
erscheinen lässt und noch ein basic fun
fact am ende der beta etwa 700
lichtjahre von uns entfernt ist braucht
das licht des sterns 700 jahre für den
weg zur erde heißt also im klartext das
gigantische spektakel hat möglicherweise
bereits schon längst stattgefunden denn
das licht das wir derzeit von dem über
riesen sehen wurde ja bereits vor 700
jahren ausgestrahlt fachleute wissen
also gar nicht wie der monsters stern
derzeit wirklich aussieht abhilfe könnte
der japanische detector hyper kam mir
kann das schaffen der in sechs jahren in
einer bergwerk höhle installiert werden
soll
der plan sieht vor hier neutrinos in
einem gigantischen wassertank
aufzufangen
diese geister teilchen entstehen ja in
den zentren von sternen und deren
neutrino strahlung steigt schon einige
tage an
bevor ein stern überhaupt explodiert
hyper kam york an das könnte uns also
eine art frühwarnsystem für supernovae
bieten sind alle bäume graziös hammer
video vom mathematiker bei es 1050 der
fuchs anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
doch fuchs natürlich bis dann bleibt
dran